[Applause]
let me just first say the state of our
union is [ __ ] ridiculous just I don't
even know where to start but I'm gonna
start with Jeff Bezos is dick because
it's in the news and we don't know how
big this is gonna get the story but did
you see this is a Jeff Bezos richest man
in the world owns the Washington Post
which attacks Donald Trump and the
National Inquirer works for Donald Trump
and attacks Robert Wagner but also Jeff
Bezos and so it's a real billionaire
with a real newspaper against the fake
billionaire with the fake newspaper and
the Washington Post's motto is democracy
dies in darkness and the Enquirer's
motto is Jennifer Aniston has twins but
Loni Anderson viii them you following
this so far so the Enquirer got hold
last week did you see these oh my god
they're pretty embarrassing of texts
from Jeff Bezos showing that he is
having an affair with Lauren Sanchez a
TV personality I don't know what that
means
so Jeff Bezos said hey The Enquirer did
it on the orders of Trump they're
working for Trump and The Inquirer said
shut up about that you said up about
that we're gonna show everybody your
dick and they'll know it's your dick
Jeff Bezos because under the dick it
will say there are some other dicks that
you might enjoy
I know it's insane but Bezos dick is
hanging tough because it said that it
said he said he fired back today he said
go ahead show my dick to the world you
can't blackmail me because I'm telling
you on you on you first so I applaud
that and don't lose faith in democracy
people this is how it isn't the larger
question have dick pics ever worked I
mean Jeff I know you're rich but there's
something you should know there is
something in your pants that makes women
want to [ __ ] you your wallet okay now if
anybody is from Virginia I feel so sorry
for you this is the rat [ __ ] e estate
I've ever say a third virginia
politician now has admitted to wearing
blackface i mean this is the republican
now thomas Norment he was the managing
editor at the VMI yearbook and there are
photographs in there a black face also
slurs against african-americans Asians
and Jews of course Republicans handle
this differently than Democrats do he
has been answering calls now to step up
[Applause]
and the governor of Virginia this guy is
just an idiot I'm sorry this Ralph
Northam how did he ever get through
Medical School he's been trying to tough
it out after admitting to wearing
blackface in the 80s to enter a dance
contest as Michael Jackson and now
ironically everybody is telling him to
beat it he's just an idiot I interviewed
a lot of politicians sometimes they just
are I mean he was at a press conference
trying to explain this away and a
reporter Pulitzer Prize in the offing
I'm sure here asked can you still
moonwalk and this idiot governor started
looking around like do I have enough
space to bust a move and his wife
thank God the wife whispers
inappropriate where was she thirty years
ago when he came out of the bathroom is
Michael Jackson I mean so Democrats
Democrats in Virginia are in big trouble
because the lieutenant governor may go
down for sexual assault allegations and
now rape allegations and the third guy
another Democrat also wore black face in
the 80s to impersonate Kurtis Blow guys
in Virginia two words
Phil Collins Louis Phil Collins go is
sting Billy Idol wings
Backman Turner overdrive there are
choices choices the Golden Bough
[Music]
the Russians are like do we even need to
meddle in this democracy itself [ __ ]
up speaking of the Russians Trump gave
his State of the Union speech on Tuesday
he lied his ass off for 82 minutes Nancy
Pelosi I love this picture of her behind
it just she had her no [ __ ] left to
give face today Donald Trump had his
physical his second physical as a
president close call
during the rectal exam this is serious
during the exam the doctor thought he
felt something took it was just Sean
Hannity
you